Chris Matteo Lane I love my woman yeah
we have a podcast called inside the
closet yeah Matteo Lane is here you can
see him on Netflix and to me I think
you've done the world of comedy and
entertainment a great service by
bringing Barbara Corcoran you know
because I want to tell you a story about
a young girl and she became a waitress
and when she was struggling
she got a loan for $1,000 from that loan
became I'm out looks like Lady Layne
Fairchild from Mister Rogers
neighborhood yeah talking about were
talking about Barbara korkin barber from
shark tank yeah she's my favorite she'll
always ask how did you come up with that
idea
interesting I know but she like I always
I always bring her it because at first
of all I love cuz I'm watching the
Netflix special and I'm like I can't
tell half the people in this room have
no idea what he's talking about but he
could give a [ __ ] because he's doing the
bottle if it's that I mean it was either
that or do my Liza Minnelli impression
those are the best impressions I do but
antegrade Joe Mackey I've heard you do a
good job no I do a really good job
Mackey I talk just like Joe
it's a Morel he I'm the kid not him a
great Sam but I do a wonderful as
Minnelli but I feel like most your
audience has no idea lies me like I'm my
favorite is if you watched our tank went
like literally one time there was two
guys up there and she she like she just
she'll throw you a curve ball she's like
you know what I'm really enthusiastic
about your product but not enthusiastic
about you you knew all the answers
you're too smart you're too slick and
I'm gonna go with my gut I'm out someone
will come in with like a bowl of man is
she's like I'm in for eight hundred
thousand dollars for one percent of your
company I have a theory that I've been
trying to push about Barbara Corcoran
for a long time go on she has no money
to her name every dollar that she has
she invested in that stupid lobster
truck knowing that hot pink suit that
she insists on wearing all the time
because because I swear I have never
seen her invest in one idea other than
the lobster truck there was a
so I can what i think what time i went
for ice cream really go based off my
stomach if I'm hungry you're getting a
deal
that's it it's like going grocery
shopping when you have anything uh yeah
yeah you know I don't think she has any
cash everybody even Robert Herjavec
eventually so sick of his story you know
my father was a Croatian my god I know
we know I mean it's the same thing this
mark looks like he's wearing a mask I
mean it's been ten seasons so many
stories to tell I love that and one time
bar she had a little work done and I I
wouldn't say I had work done but I would
say that I have a new face um she one
time there was less someone's handing
out like syrup or something and then you
could just hear her in the back and go
oh so Barbara Corcoran you know they
have Mark Cuban on the show so you gotta
watch it it's a great show and tell
comics love the show it's so great it's
I mean everyone loves it but
specifically kinda like Ryan Hamilton
and I and Nikki Glaser are obsessed with
Shark Tank
Plus that if you have a TV you can watch
her for five minutes and get the same
amount out of it you could watch it for
five minutes
or eight hours it's all the same it's
really good you know they have Mark
Cuban who everybody knows mr. wonderful
kevin O'Leary who's you know he's not so
wonderful I'm doing Cheri Oteri scoville
Walters or some mix above a crooked but
I'm excited and people seem to like it
Damon on who's the guy who created black
guy yeah I created with never yeah yeah
yeah you created FUBU
we interviewed him I remember he was a
nice man right they have this woman from
QVC Laurie the one worry I'm out for
that reason right hey Mel unless she
thinks she can sell it on QVC then she's
in she's also the one like everyone
seems to have like normal lighting and
then hers as if Jesus opened up the
gates of heaven it's like really bright
lighting like Lahori cuz it's the same
with Mariah Carey I met Mariah Carey two
weeks ago hi Sean yeah yeah you meet her
MTV was like doing fans meet her in an
elevator the producer knew me and threw
me in there and and she was great she
was well lit and nervous but yeah but it
was so weird cuz we're all in this
shitty elevator and the lighting is
horrible and then there's Mariah like
like lit by God and you say to her you
know I was like I love you do you love
her no I do I love I mean I've had so I
have a history with Mariah Carey like
I've had a love/hate relationship with
her but she's on a really good path
right now and she's working towards her
voice and she's like you know seems not
like she's good
why'd you hate her because she was with
this horrible manager named Stella and
making weird choices and I just thought
her legacy was better than that you were
hold your father you followed pretty
closely
oh I mean like a hawk Wow like all these
Mariah Carey like Instagram accounts
just to see like how what notes she's
hitting live and good I would literally
rather listen to the Khashoggi murder
but she's got a great voice
like I know she has an amazing voice
it's just not what I like what about
that for specific people by specific I
mean gays
you didn't tap out on Mariah Carey when
she did that New Year's performance that
she just went happen to like her a
little more because she's the one person
where something like that can happen to
her and she's just like yeah I don't
care
you mean like she never that's it like
and it's kind of over but then also when
you have a teen number one's everyone's
like yeah sure with that Christmas song
it's okay yeah I'm fine you know that
Christmas song is number eight in the
country right now not in digital holiday
charts the number eight song in the
country now is Mariah Carey's all I want
for Christmas is you who comes out with
a Christmas song that actually turns
into a Christmas song Mariah Carey like
those songs are already well established
for you did it didn't they have one so
this is Christmas John Lennon that's a
Beatle and then Paul Paul think I want
to wish you a Merry Christmas I want oh
no that's a Felicia oh yeah that was one
Crosby why it's so funny to listen to
music and be like he just beat the [ __ ]
out of his kid I know makes me enjoys
music more actually feels so warm and
wholesome yeah and just destroying them
physically by the way right now rich is
struggling on the toilet you think so
not going little legs are straight out
by he left going yeah I don't do my legs
what but as you watch the shark tank
show the greatest dynamics in the world
to me number there's three great
dynamics on the show number one is Mark
Cuban he has this way you know when you
buy things on eBay the best thing you
can do is snipe like you there's makes
no sense to bid on anything on eBay days
in advance you have to wait until 30
seconds ten seconds before the auction
ends and you just come in and quickly
bid just buy it outright it will if it's
an auction you can't get right you know
people you know sometimes stressful but
like Mark Cuban does that on the Shark
Tank he'll just you all right rich how
did everything we were discussing how
well your [ __ ] was going do is
struggling you were struggling can you
[ __ ] publicly like you can do that you
know the line of you it's the easiest
humor in the world and these guys that's
what they do they're like suddenly it's
taking a [ __ ] Willie Reid's great
newspapers like The Enquirer like the
morning after it after it's been pushed
off into you depends if I'm getting
something right now no so things are
going great you have a boy you know I
don't have a boyfriend anymore just we
sing really mm-hmm what a great what a
great life being gay why did you hit did
you hate your boyfriend you beat him I
know I'm not a piece of [ __ ] I didn't
hit my boyfriend in the gay communities
you generally accepted the military not
one person right that's the first you've
ever got rich of all the things the gays
of John you can hit your boyfriend you
understand rich knows a lot about being
gay but just not living a gay lifestyle
he understands I've seen his outfits he
knows very well what it's like to live a
gay life no one said gays are the best
dressers they're just they just dress
differently you don't think age you're
better dresser sometimes no and in gays
would admit that too there's gays
walking another it's like girl you know
I mean but we choose but the best
dresses and make the best dresses love
them
mm-hmm okay - we were I mean we were
doing we did like 15 minutes of show
tank yeah we're talking about shark tank
and everything yeah the first dynamic is
mark you've been jumping in and uh and
sniping up purchases like in the middle
of a negotiation you know whoever Lori
Beth will go I'll do $500,000 for 20%
and the guy goes will you do 15 and Lori
goes hmm and Marcos y'all do it they go
but mr. Wonderful's like I'll give you
the money but it's a loan and I want to
point three percent back and then
negative five and if you take this ion
I'm like wait a minute this is confusing
for everyone I learned I learned all my
business acumen from mr. wonderful on
that show and that's why when we were
negotiating our serious deal all I did
was tell my agent I don't want to sign
anything in perpetuity never like you
gotta stop makes no sense like they go
whoa what did you bring in last year
four million and you need a $75,000 all
that expose what was the big one I love
the shirt sister Lori was the biggest
has the biggest selling product was the
sponge but that's really face mister
scrub yeah whatever they're called
something they're phenomenal
sponges sponges how much money I don't
know but I know I love this shirt yeah
most comfortable shirts good shirts I
have two of them send me a scrub daddy
shirt there I was a DDP yoga went on the
show you know DDP went on to do DDP yoga
and all the Sharks were like I don't
think there's anything to invest in here
and DDP was like yeah I guess not and he
was like dude do you understand after I
did Shark Tank in 48 hours
I did seven figures in sales he was like
it was just a complete figure seven like
a million dollars for commercial but if
it's a commercial you got to behave well
I mean you can't go on and cry
people who cry yeah it's like just
because you know everyone your family's
dying doesn't mean that your products
any better you know no you're a hundred
percent right I'm like what that doesn't
make this t-shirt better yeah why would
I still buy this yeah [ __ ] family's
dead but the second dynamic is this guy
Robert Herjavec is on there and he hair
plugs great hair plugs he's a he's a
Canadian guy but he's an immigrant and
all this stuff and he founded a his
father's the immigrant from Croatia his
hairline has been sliding up and down
that forehead for years [ __ ] here nobody
take it out look I can't because I'm
starting to lose my hair so I can't wait
till I can get hair plugs my hairline is
gonna start in like two centimeters but
you Andrew Schulz yesterday talked about
taking propecia
I know propecia I tried it for three
months and felt like I was a zombie why
the [ __ ] you up it made me feel like a
zombie [ __ ] you up I heard you it wasn't
sexual nothing I mean just like nothing
Wow agent just like a blob
I wasn't liking here it's in the back
over here and then it's starting to
creep that way but I still as I've
sculpted it in a way so it's like longer
on the sides and I blow it out and then
bring it forward but what's interesting
is like when it's windy out cuz I've
sculpted it I have to like move my head
to whatever direction the winds going so
are you worried now about losing your
like is there something you like [ __ ] no
I was at first and I'm like whatever
I'll just go to the gym
that's smart yeah you just I I this is
what I have control over let me focus on
yeah I got control over my pectoral
muscles yeah but I'm not that where it's
it's managing to look like something
right now you're scared that your
forehead will look like his someday you
know it's so funny like from your
eyebrows up you're the bad guy from home
alone - and home are ya that was the
name from the Wet Bandits yeah Daniel
Stern yeah wonder is he doing no sir it
looks like Randy Quaid that's how I'm
gonna look like when I die the skeleton
but Robert Herjavec
every time on that show he offers a deal
and every time they turn him down
it just seems like a like a boob I don't
my name's like - like a what like you
can walk over them it's almost like
everyone everyone but me well that's the
third dynamic is the Barbara Corcoran
never never gives anybody any money
because she doesn't have any I'm just
every bullet mayonnaise and some lobster
then why is she there every time I don't
know every time she said that she made
her money in real estate but every time
I watch the show I'm just waiting for
her to be like could we look at how much
she's worth yeah she's like seventy
million dollars you know she's got a you
know what I love the product I think
that you guys are great unfortunately
I'm a little cash poor right now for
that reason I'm out unfortunately have
no idea what I'm doing here so I'm out
how a million that's what it says good I
don't believe it
so thinks I mean at least she's she
worked she was a businesswoman to author
from Edgewater
from Jersey I guess so okay I do not
want to shocked
yeah marks worth the most the mark could
buy everybody out on that lineup right
well marks like marketer yeah Jim but he
also started like networking computer
network and they got in on that early
and that's how he made most of his money
any any bought a ton of domain names
really early oh you got like sandwich
calm and pickle calm and all this stuff
very early smart yeah it for him I was
able to sell it but mr. wonderful has a
lot of money too I mean I've been trying
to move Jim Norton and Sam Roberts off
of Sirius XM and onto the something
wonderful platform you know what you
think something wonderful platform well
I was with four hundred million dollars
see Kevin O'Leary he's the greatest he's
my favorite by a mile
yeah you know a nice of Chicago accents
watch more Cuban worth a billion dollars
I mean he's gotta go yeah he's so much
my guest five billion but could be I
guess three point nine nine nine billion
holy and he's young too well let's not
say things we can't take back
I mean years old but when you're when
you're rich boss you remembers he
remembers six yeah you're older than him
yes sixty is young if you're rich
thank you you do 61 thank you yeah you
know he doesn't look as good as they
used to with his shirt off it's not
happening today amazing shape I know you
know every time with him he insists on
showing me as abs and I've never showed
him mine I see internet every day I know
my Instagram is so I'm sorry everybody
I know you're drinking milk comic what
happened years ago what I'm joking I'm
just saying I love Lucas she bosses ABS
on the internet every day - do you think
Mark Cuban will go into politics um I
don't think so we would know by now I
think I think I think so no which is a
dumb question well you're talking about
ABS he's trying to get the conversation
off of him take that shirt off well we
couldn't steer this right back there no
you've never seen rich with his shirt
off hey you show me every like every day
with the shirt all the way like I've
gotta wait wait wait wait wait that's
not fair
no it's not we have to beg for it yeah
you look at the second one yeah rich you
look good
rich you show Mateo you'll take your
shirt off for Mateo and not for us no
stop it
it's not listen it's not even sort of
Cola hickey let's not do you look like
my Instagram on this Google search did
you know his pictures online did you
know that rich went on bennington show
and said that we were hacks and not a
real radio show because we make him take
his shirt off I said that [ __ ] hog and
say you was talking about wanting to see
a friend you said a bit tacky and you
said we're not a real radio show
probably okay he'll go somewhere in just
badmouth his friends exactly and he
wonders why everybody hates him exactly
not everybody every club do you feel
like we're entitled to a bit of an
apology after the hundred percent I
wonder how do you like to receive
apologies the shirt stinks what do you
know go get the malla stop it Dominic
can we take a vote and if it did happen
which it's not it's at the end of the
show I'm not taking my shirt off in
front of Adonis over here Terry he's
your friend Mateo is a Christmas present
yet
no he hasn't no I didn't know that was a
thing you guys running out of material
let's do some let's talk we are we're
talking about you know microphone use
your instrument shouting up now this is
[Laughter]
[ __ ] in the Upper East Side
everyone's in their early hundreds
you've never done Broadway no off
Broadway no no's well as you sing yeah
you try for living trying to destroy
commercials for the storyboarding right
yes your horrid TV commercials I was
fine I mean some commercials were worse
than others but I did a lot of fashion
ads because I can draw pretty women
bending teach Christmas nuts this year
last year you sang opera right probably
yeah but it was amazing Thanks amazing
this guy is so talented you have to see
him with his shirt off it's a just goes
to my Instagram you'll see it right
there
whatever yeah that's the thing about
like Matteo chose to be a comedian he
could have been a singer rich could have
been a body build a bio model be a
speech therapist do you think rich could
have been a torso model absolutely
probably yes he can go into a store me
like that's me he could have been Shaq's
body double and that's not commercial
photoshoping they are very clever
doesn't bother me it's so funny the way
they do it they can they make you look
really stupid
yeah Remy you look like a man TZ why are
you being so distracting because because
why because like say this weekend when
I'm in Doylestown Saturday at the
Cabaret great club the problem with this
and this is why I'm not doing the Tate a
hundred percent I promise you I'll walk
out I'm cursed a yellow every place now
is yelling take your shirt off
don't you think if you don't do it and
make a hole pressure really
yeah guys doing [ __ ] sold-out shows
her shirt off yes it is that's because
she does Rogan every other week that's
and he's funny
rich tried to make a joke out of it and
then realize just joking saying that he
takes his shirt off and he sells on
George okay then he gives me a real
answer well no technically I know he
does Rogan yeah I'm saying it I like the
Joe Rogan podcast million other people I
know but like you know it's not really
Rick aren't you worried singular or
plural pick Elaine aren't you worried
that by name and I know an answer to
that but aren't you worried that by not
taking your shirt off no I'm not it's
gonna make more people in Doylestown
this weekend where you're performing
shout that they want to see you do it
yeah there because they didn't get to
see you do it on our social media yeah
just get it out of the way now don't you
feel like 15 people see it you're not
doing Rogan dude listen you guys just to
differ between you guys and rogues
what's the difference in numbers that's
right he said yeah that was my did you
ever says we're good friends I'm friends
with Rogan but you guys I would do
anything for Thank You Shirley so one
thing we like
great time
come on June we have a guest would you
impress oh no he see me if I wasn't here
would you have taken you know yeah what
I gained weight [ __ ] that's what you
were doing in the bathroom you were
posing in the best lighting and you're
like not yeah Richard you're
embarrassing us in front of a guest do
you really think when you go come on
you're embarrassing us in front of our
guests yeah we have a friend here
company we're trying to impress the
potato get him to come back soon
but if he goes oh they can't even get
rich to take his shirt off like I'm
gonna call my agent
rich wouldn't take his shirt off I'm not
coming back exactly I don't want that to
happen it's embarrassing Pilar Mateo is
given be performing at the DC draft
house in DC San Francisco Sketchfest jfl
Northwest in San Francisco they had that
and roar at the MGM he's [ __ ]
hilarious come DC Drafthouse I fourth
and fifth of January it's gonna be
freezing cold and I I'll just need money
love yeah yeah yeah everybody check it
out rich you take your shirt off No are
you doing any wrestling stuff coming up
yeah don't you do a live podcast do you
have a live one coming I don't have a
live one coming up I'll be in San Jose
for doing stuff for the double W e
network the weekend are you going over
there are you going this weekend wow
that's cool yeah you back on Monday I
pray view late on Monday okay I'm
reading back on Monday or Sunday night
yeah
get here Monday fly you back and forth
no it was first class they fighting back
and forth
first class is this show ending right
now no okay guy got nervous
no we have plenty of time already stop
stop how am I gonna stop if you don't
just do it the only way to get me to
stop is just to do it it's not happening
I'm gassy I'm bloated I ate chicken parm
last night my on at the shell oh you
could have them take a cutlet I know you
told me last week and then put marinara
you can't tell an Italian that it's
trouble the chicken color there is great
yeah it is good on it
little so let's go to a literate Georgia
yeah that's what I was looking at what's
up litter hey Michael hi
ring doorbell yeah they rejected that on
short I made some bad moves turn it down
some [ __ ] clunkers it happens I mean
it's like playing the stock market some
sometimes you make a great bet and other
times you you [ __ ] loser a lot of
money I watch where I watch the be out
you watch beyond the tank to know i
watch beyond the tank and they go back
to you know look at the businesses they
watch repeats of the tank that you've
seen already the Jackson and I watch it
yeah and barbers in most all it rotates
right because I don't like I'll look as
they up gets Laurie I want Barbara no I
don't like as much what they're doing
with the new seasons where they bring on
like Alex Rodriguez and Ashton Kutcher
get out of here stop it with your
business man please exactly him and
Justin Timberlake are the most obnoxious
people in Hollywood you think so we're
funny shut up you're not yeah yeah and I
don't like there's the guy who dresses
like a cowboy I don't remember his name
but he always gets into fights our
Cerrone I don't think it's done it was
Susan Boyle met Susan Boyle yeah but I
watched like beyond the tank that's
where they go and they go to the
businesses they've already invested in
uh-huh and I watched one where it was a
guy who invented like a red plastic Solo
Cup but on the bottom of it there was a
shot glass
oh yeah that's like a party thing and
Daymond invested all this money into it
and you just watch the guy get crushed
because he was not a good businessman
according to Damon and he rescinded his
offer I'm being the tank really yeah oh
yeah he's just like look I don't think
there's any business for us we can do it
during the episode or after after I'm
beyond the tank but wait wow there's a
shot glass under glass oh yeah it's
sitting on the chocolate like the bottom
of the cup is like shaped like so you
turn over it so you can drink a drink
bro right wait a minute I don't
understand it's a very bro we thing it's
like a Red Solo Cup right and you hold
it you hold it there but if you flip it
upside down like you're playing a
drinking game hey VIN see that look yeah
it's a shot glass yeah I mean I don't
get it it's ridiculous to drink more
yeah because you can do a shot and
something else out of the same Cup we I
mean you do it at the same time drink
that flip it over and pour
with beer prices use two cups are so
dumb I don't have ETS [ __ ] liquid all
over the place yeah it sounds a mess
it's for France like people play beer
pong like it's okay they don't know Adam
against this I hate it Majid reading
something they're putting on the table
you leave the [ __ ] ring it's
disgusting yeah doesn't it seem messy
aren't you gonna pick up the germs from
the table Italian mother my mother you
don't even drink you're sober I know
that but I still I don't like germs
thank you do it with juice we shot in
one side and orange juice on the other
yes
no I mean like it's for people who don't
mind like sharing cups and just do just
want to get alcohol in their systems and
that way they can play their little
flippy cup games and all there's more
fun alcohol to be poured in from other
bombs on this show that they had besides
my act Ashton Kutcher on that show he
sucks everywhere he's really
good-looking I mean that's the problem
is that he's just completely he's a good
profile everything same when they put a
celebrity on Project Runway yes you know
about fashion well that's I get mad when
you watch chopped and it's like some
seedless CW star sitting there knows
these people are murdering themselves to
make this ridiculous meal made of duct
tape and eel and then they come up there
sweating their family's on the line and
then this star is like yeah I like the
color pink I'm like the [ __ ] are you
doing here I hate what here's what I
hate about Ashton Kutcher on the show
mr. wonderful will do like the most mr.
wonderful things ever and he'll go you
know this idea I know you've had this
idea it's your baby you've it's it's
it's everything you've invested
everything into it you have to know when
you have a dog and this dog needs to be
brought behind this shed and shot and
then you're just like watching this
person's dreams get crushed
but Ashton Kutcher is the guy that'll be
like hey this is this person's dream you
don't need to be rude oh I like that you
don't have you know you need a Simon
Cowell you need someone to be like you
suck which was too wonderful he's in the
middle with the mr. clean the overweight
mr. clean yes Barbara ladling fair chap
mr. Rochester neighborhood on the left
and the mask from saws all the way on
the left that is a mark
and then yeah Robert Herjavec well do
you have a overweight mr.clean than a
black mr. clean in the middle weight
today
they rotate people for each episode yeah
they not for like every sometimes they
team up take power but you know usually
it's like either Lori or they usually
are five people what I'll claim the fame
now she which one is that one queen yeah
QVC Green she's beautiful was she about
early hundreds you can't tell she's so
well lit I mean it literally looks like
she's filmed underwater it's blurry it
looks like a memory you have no idea
what you're looking at she reported
similar to Lindsay Lohan's Instagram
she's 49
she looks great yeah I mean you know
it's just QVC she's gothic good makeup
skin hair all that stuff right and she
generally invests in products that
somebody could just bring like that she
can sell on QVC and she makes a ton of
money for people all these like the
inventions that do well on Shark Tank
are all the ones that you see it end
caps at Bed Bath & Beyond every single
update their like their last minute
thought gets like be fun all of them
every single update they go you know
before we went on Shark Tank we were
making everything out of our garage and
now we're at every Bed Bath and Beyond
by the way that store in the country Bed
Bath and Beyond it is the best store in
the greatly stressful I mean you walk in
your I'm stressed out the one in Chelsea
you walk in it is a stressful day it's
just just [ __ ] on top they do I love it
if I had room I partners I buy things
there's also a store in the mall that
has just this stuff you see on TV good
as seen on TV yeah all this stuff that
you can't you know bet the infomercial
stuff which I think stuff to magic
bullet magic bullet is the best and for
much of you guys see the magic wow so
much oh yeah
first of all it's like really and
hosting some blonde woman and they're
like at some like they're like with
friends making breakfast and they're
doing the usual thing like you can do
this and then some grizzled there she is
with the cigarette go back to the images
some grizzled woman named hazel comes
down and she literally goes if you click
on the third picture or the cities in
the housecoat she comes down she's like
I hate garlic's stinking nasty garlic
and she's smoking a cigarette
that makes no sense it's so memorable
it's like well hazel if you take this
and that you know but she just was look
at her
great let's share your Terry character
I've never seen that infomercial but now
I'm gonna like seek out oh it's so good
just Google I mean magic bullet
information and by the way like I know
why you see all this stuff because CNBC
and I talked about it when Howie Mandel
was in here the Deal or No Deal is one
of the few shows that I'll accept taking
away my Shark Tank marathons but like
CNBC they'll run shark tank because the
stock stirred once the stock market
closes they got nothing to do on that
chance right like lifetime like put
another Golden Girls on yeah
so they'll run shark tank from like 7
p.m. until 2 a.m.
three nights a week every week and
comics are grateful and then at 2 a.m.
infomercials until the stock market that
late normally is that while you're
watching them I'm usually up that way
watching Mariah Carey high note
compilation videos god daum is true then
I wake up and watch the view but yeah I
mean I I love in for my cousin and I
used to stay up and wait for
infomercials I love infomercials at
about food
turbo cooker Magic Bullet said I forget
it honey all of it I love all of it
because it's just it's just it is that
to me the most entertaining thing in the
world
great I bought it off it uh the things
you put between your car seat and your
console down there that catches
everything oh yeah is the French fry huh
yeah I bought two of those two for $20
of what you buy them off TV when you
like you call actually I can see my door
I see Minister I also offer Amazon I saw
these other things you put between your
car seat that puts extra stuff in it
whatever just it's like an extra glove
compartment you think rich is a good
describer of things not all that awful
put it between your car seat it put
extra stuff in it no you catch I'll take
an 8 you're all telling you something
it's like a three-year-olds growing like
is this a house no this is a
your car see put stuff in ya how many
this many put extra stuff I'll invest
you know I don't know what you're
talking about but I like you and I
invest in people I've no idea were you
talking about Canada Stanley accent
sounds like you have a list Jocko it's a
700 million for your company I had an
idea this is so true and my friend and I
were gonna do it where you take a like a
punching bag and you have maybe this
much spring on it what your boyfriend's
face on beat their boyfriend yeah and
with a crier with a clamp you can put it
on your golf cart hold on we push people
when you play golf you get so [ __ ]
man instead of breaking a club you could
hit a punching bag a novelty thing right
so we never went anywhere with it by the
way do you know what kind of [ __ ] you
look like on a golf course with a
punching bag then I saw online yeah this
guy invented the same punching bag with
a suction there's a G at the end of the
word with a suction cup 300 million hits
where's it go punching bag for your desk
punching for your desk
we can't even believe that that's there
it is that's not the same those [ __ ]
fly off the desk yeah well me suction
300 million hits on Facebook so they
took your idea they made it better and
they sold it that was my idea they just
had the same ideas they blamed it well
you know I was like a clamp on your golf
bag like a punching bag you put a clamp
on the bottom of that you could clamp it
onto your [ __ ] golf course no I'm
your [ __ ] guarantee so why don't you
just invent it anyway a golf club look
if you learn anything have motivation
and I don't have the money to patent it
I think 10 grand that's a lot after you
learn on Shark Tank though they're like
where what what do you own what stops me
every time mr. wonderful just kills
everybody he goes let me ask you
something if I like your idea what would
stop me from making
the mr. wonderful punching bag and
clamping that onto my golf cart and they
go well we were first to market well
we're here yeah how do say we have a
patent if they have a pass the point
never they don't if they don't they're
for yeah yeah what are you gonna say
wrench tell me patents are very they're
easy to get around cuz all he has to do
is add one little thing to it that's
right and then it's you know so that's
right it's the same with when you write
something put in the writers guild or
protect it it's so easy to go around it
and just take your show or your idea now
I here's what I do I write all my ideas
and then I mail them to myself it's
foolproof
that's right nobody's gonna ream me off
I just write in my notes yeah email it
to yourself helps what to have the date
on it yep so it's stamped does help
mm-hmm I have people stalling your ideas
before rich he's nodding yep what I did
did they steal Richard the bullet the
magic from a gun you won't believe it
but I'll tell you that you invented the
bullet No
eighteen seventeen nineteen seventy with
your shirt off bra no in 1977 a friend
of mine who was an artist
we took sneakers this is 100% true and
weed and I we drew checkers on them
right and it was red and white I was the
only one who I said to my father can you
give me money so we can get this
business started
he said you're always trying to get rich
quick those are probably a multi he was
trying to get rid of you know but you
know I'll talk about the sneakers with
the second when did manse come out with
the check sneakers rock drop see if it's
before 77 it's a 1942 those sneakers
yeah I mean that was like vans first
thing right yeah so 65 okay so they were
doing you were 13 years late
no nobody did those weren't their first
pair yeah see you like a vans Wikipedia
you did something fancy created a tent
at least 10 years before you know they
didn't yeah you were late rich no no no
absolutely late again that's like me
inventing a scrub daddy now feel like
you idiot yeah let's see
pitocin occurs before founded in 1916
1944 ok Snickers didn't come out until
the 80s that's not true
how do you know you don't you're Saints
facts you don't know nobody had those
sneakers when we did it on to prevent
vans had already done except Larry Vance
all right Troy you're kind of a fan of
van sneakers right yeah would you say
that they probably they had those check
sneakers pretty early in the game I'm
sure yeah see there's no proof you can't
go to corn go on I'm sure you just ask
vans when they did it and they would
actually they would just prove no we did
it to me now why would they you I don't
need to what would you guys invent if
you went on Shark Tank I haven't thought
about that I know I wish I have never
have any invention ideas for as much as
I watch that show
I've never you have to think of
something kind of clever that no one
else is something that annoys you every
day yo son you like oh yeah there's no
thing for that they're like I have to do
is solve a problem that we all have and
I'm like I'm right now okay whoever
takes it if you want to send me 10% cuz
they don't have it's like when you give
away your password on the air if you
want to give me 10% golf pants okay guys
I love golfing but it really does yeah
what's they come down [ __ ] little
bouncing castle you can bring on the
golf course they come down like flares
right but on the inside they're tight
there's a they're tight to your skin so
ticks can't crawl up your legs so
there's like the leg is is tight to your
skin why the flair for the look for the
look so it doesn't look like you're
wearing just tights on the bottom it
takes a big problem golf yeah and well
injures which may mean lingers like
joggers that have they're kind of baggy
sweatpants but
at the ankles well they're pants pants
but United ankles I mean 30 and did the
cats and [ __ ] culottes no no you
gotta get to the ankles because chicks
will go anyway their second like that's
joggers you're describing they already
exist where you could just wear socks
and I do I pull the socks over my pants
then problems they you know you have
some [ __ ] Night Stalker
that's what Richard Ramirez would do
anything rape old ladies yes because he
didn't his pants getting caught on
anything he would tuck his pants into
his socks when he climbed into a window
look at all these so horrible look at
all these baggy pants that are tight at
the ankles 25 slacks
your slacks those are sweatpants in
their yard
he means tight underneath and then the
fabric on the outside going but like
bell-bottoms but underneath the
bell-bottoms just wear it underneath
your pee in the summer it's the same
thing difference because you're layers
over there do second layers you've got a
flair so everyone's gonna call you a
[ __ ] over that at that point the tick
wants nothing we lose that word here I
mean me Yamini is right I mean it would
just be like wearing long socks it's the
same thing you don't get it
you're stupid I'm gonna tell you rich
socks not a good idea no ticks can call
up socks and eat your skin so off they
can about this product tick what else
you invented it took you a little longer
than it should've but you're older we
just actually robbed wanted to
contribute and there rob said he's been
golfing rob is what is he 27 26 what are
you looking for Rob maybe a hat with
radar so bats don't bother you and your
golfing
he's been golfing for 15 years he said
he's only ever gotten one tick that is
correct and that's when he was in
golfing which he said it's not a problem
it was in the pants but it was one time
and I've golf i golf maybe love always
eastcoast $35 what did you do when you
and him a father-son time Oh
Rob don't say it said what's he said dad
oh my god dad and laughs I'm happy I
don't have a relationship with my father
he was in Vietnam it's got two gays sons
he's emotionally unavailable what do you
think I mean this man did know this is
hard for him everything's hard for him
he's just one of these male I haven't
spoken to my sister in seven years I
mean they're you know just like did your
parents know like very young okay well
the thing is I'm gay my brother's gay my
cousin's gay we grew up next to them so
I'm sure my mom Anne's a lot well I
guess boys just play with Barbie now I
mean they must have been so confused
sure that you but were you you know
everybody like knows there's always a
kid in school that when they come out
it's not a shock yeah nothing was
shocking when I worked at Michael's for
God's sakes right but did your parents
know like when you came out to your
parents really I mean yeah my mother
trying to pretend she's like I had no
idea
you know just trying her best to act
right of course your dad had to have
seen the writing on the wall yeah of
course right now like if my kid who
cares now nowadays like if my daughters
were gay I wouldn't care yeah some
parents don't care some stumps some
still do just sad thing rich maybe it's
different for a guy if you if I had a
son then daughters you know maybe you
know maybe you expect more out of a out
of a son you know I fought in Vietnam
and I you know he's gonna be some right
yeah you know and then you're my dad
tried to take me hunting it just never
works that's seen in the Simpsons when
Homer tries to take Bart hunting and
Bart looks at him and he goes why'd you
take me and Homer goes well to learn to
be a man why what's the problem in
barkos I don't know a bunch of guys
sitting here alone in the woods
seems kind of gay yeah and Homer goes
that is a very immature entity that was
it
for Heine yeah i mean i would sing
disney princess music I just was in my
own world that there was a video of us
ice fishing can you imagine me ice
fishing but there's a vehicle ice
creeeeam of course I'm with all my
cousins and that my dad or my sister is
holding up a fish she caught I'm in the
background holding up my Pole
re-enacting Maleficent
Sleeping Beauty and the video just cuts
by my father going mad yes I mean it's
not like your dad would have been
totally supportive of me right my
brother yeah he loves us very much he's
just you know emotionally not there he's
gone through a lot of course he's gone
through life and I forget you I'm like
forgive him you know what I mean like
he's watching his friends die in Vietnam
I'm like oh god grinders a drag I have
to put it into perspective you know so I
sort of I've been nicer to my dad in my
upbringing he's 64 we have a caller who
actually thinks that Rich's invention
yeah says something about his golf game
I mean I'm in the woods
Eric in New Jersey guessing punch lines
for just let a guy tell a joke two Jews
walk into a bra you're like I'm not
gonna take my shirt off and I'm gonna
give away people's well first of all
this is like shark tank and I'm gonna
have to argue back go ahead caller
you're on not what shark tank is that's
my ball yeah okay it's Eric in New
Jersey pretty darn close I just want to
know you know why where is your ball
landing okay okay I'm gonna tell you
this right now cow where I play well I
in Central Jersey tons of deer and
there's so much fescue there and you
don't have to hit your ball there the
wind will blow a tick okay you don't
have to walk there's just to flying
through the air like sharknado except
she knows Alfred Hitchcock like the
birds it was tick tick can fly birds
weren't getting blown around they fly
now today would fly in this scenario no
wind can blow it anything Barbara's
still on board for this one
now years ago the wind can blow a tick
so Eric and eat so Eric rich you're
protecting your ankles because if the
wind makes it tick air his invention
which is a golf bag with fans that blow
out this way any ticks will be blown
away from the golfing area Troy you grew
up in Pennsylvania yeah you must have
experienced a bit of the outdoors
growing up of course every spring they
had to close all the windows because the
ticks were blowing into the house ready
to deal with flying ticks I'm sure has
picked up a tick before right I mean
once in a while a [ __ ] house gets
blown due to a tornado or hurricane if
there are ticks flying through the air
it wouldn't it wouldn't explain why you
made the protection in the ankle area
say I know what if it blows Mary Kate
conversations I'm blowing it's
contradicting I mean you okay get it I'm
I don't need them on what if it lands on
your shoe and then crawls up your leg
[ __ ]
you know how many things would have to
happen for your invention to even sort
of be a little irrelevant it's crawl up
your legs you're on the dirt in the
middle of the course how many concrete
yeah exactly whatever it's my idea and
when I sell it actually we just found
out contrary to popular belief ticks do
not fly or jump they do not blow in the
wind or fall from trees where does it
say to land on your head
ticks legs can detect carbon dioxide
ba-ba-ba-ba ticks do not jump takes do
not fall on you ticks don't do any of
that stuff they got they cometh on the
ground and they crawl up your life not
yet not the new jersey central tick new
jersey central take not central New
Jersey I think the New Jersey centralite
Delta right Richard would you think
would you take your shirt off no we're
gonna take a break there are a couple
people that want to say hi to red
all right if we should bring them in
sure you know Dennis Falcone was outside
he loves he wanted to bring in a couple
people to say hi to rich so if we could
please welcome Dennis Falcone and his
shirtless Balloon Boy thank you for
gracing us with your presence and
bringing your shirtless balloon boys
this is like why are you coughing and
being pretending you're not liking that
yeah cuz I got this damn guys the
music's on dance with rich yeah no don't
steal all the fun yeah take your shirt
off damn yeah rich take your shirt off
[Laughter]
yeah rich join the party man
Troi yeah you'll be great Troy do you
want to join the party right then you
know it don't be shy
you know what the shirtless balloon boys
do when you won't take your shirt off
[Applause]
that's right touch the autistic
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
the toplessness is contagious this was
gonna happen but when Dennis Falcone
shirtless balloon boys show up there's
really only one thing you can do you do
your I'll put your line I can't you know
what what if I could get you to is
Friday Saturday and oils tena to comedy
cabaret to dance music now they don't
need the music yeah yeah this shirtless
bloom wait you know you know what Dennis
wants to see the shirtless balloon boys
make a sandwich
[Laughter]
the boss said torch boys Dennis how
great is it to have two shirtless boys
at your at your will in it you're gay
you're back cause you love it huh
I'd love to bring them to a wedding yeah
yeah but I get paid before him get the
cash up front
hatred washed smiles along all right
listen I still have two hours left in my
hotel bring the boys back like this idea
and I want to invest
Barbara Corcoran wouldn't Dancing with
the Stars oh did you see her on Dancing
with the Stars I make the whole time
like hitting on her her partner oh he's
time sexy I'm drying short what's wrong
what happened why you got tied up there
was a lot of chaos at the party the
other day I pulled away I was getting
gas mm-hmm and I thought he hit my car
and I pulled away and [ __ ] ripped the
hose that happens in like came national
lampoon's vacation and that's it can you
believe that you lied about something
horrible happened to your kids to try to
family emergency a water a furnace could
break that's an emergency family
emergency emergency
geez that's weird man
he kisses on the cheeks
how am I the least gay on this job you
are Mariah Carey impressions Barbic Liza
Minnelli impressions and I've been swept
away
well when Dennis Falcone brings in his
shirtless balloon boys there's no out
game makes everyone question everything
it really does because we all enjoy it
and nobody really knows why you know
it's life just being good see it's not
always about you taking your shirt off
sometimes it's about other guys taking
their shirt right yes and then
eventually I'll do it again but
sometimes we have to spread the wealth
right right Anthony's gyrating his
pelvis behind you he's still there still
in in mode